you know those parents who took their
young kids to see Deadpool then got
super offended by how mature the movie
was can the opening to Deadpool to just
be him delivering a PSA on the movie
rating system to all parents who don't
know better now that would be incredible
hello Internet welcome to film theory
the show that's gonna get through an
entire Deadpool episode without
mentioning chimichangas once oh wait
does that count crap but if I can get
serious here for a moment this year Bill
and Melinda Gates yes the who's Gates
reached out to me yes that me to do a
video about superpowers it's pretty
awesome right you see every year the
Gates is write a letter outlining their
take on key global issues with this
year's letter being called to
superpowers we wish we had in the letter
they challenged the reader to imagine
what their super power for good would be
the goal of the letter is to broaden
awareness and get each of us involved to
help make a positive lasting change in
the world
it's an incredibly noble cause and
honestly I'm honored to be included as a
part of the campaign it's funny but when
I think of what I can do to try and make
a positive change in the world
I honestly think of these channels
because yeah for as goofy and a name as
it might be to analyze the real-world
physics of ant-man suit or the
deadliness of a bullet bill I like to
think that it's giving you a bit of
education along the way maybe
brightening your day and so no it's not
curing cancer or anything but I'm never
gonna be the type to do that instead I
like to think that these videos make at
least some of your worlds just a little
bit happier and teach some of you at
least something new every week
who knows I might be living in a dream
world anyway sappy stuff aside as I was
thinking about what superpower I'd want
I immediately thought I want to be
Deadpool I am very turned on right now
not quite in that way I want his healing
factor in the world of comic books it's
a pretty common ability that does
exactly what it sounds like enhancing a
person's ability to recover from wounds
quickly there are tons of different
variations of the healing factor ability
across comic books but probably the two
most iconic are Wolverines and of course
Deadpool's and this relationship is no
coincidence deadpool got his healing
factor from a serum derived from
wolverine what do they just have needles
full of the stuff lying around go into
the old Walgreens get my flu vaccine and
follow up with a healing factor chaser
great sign me up
you are hard to look at oh oh is that
what happens
well good thing most of my channels are
voiceover anyway they're regenerative
ability gives them an incredibly strong
resistance to chemicals and toxins which
is great for protecting against vats of
acid and not so great for getting drunk
it also boosts the immune system
rendering them pretty well protected
against most diseases it even gives them
resistance to telepathic control so no
one's hopping into Deadpool's head
commanding him to dress as a girl he's
just doing that all on his own the
factor is so quick that it keeps the
body cells from growing old halting
aging almost completely in short
Deadpool and Wolverine are both
basically immortal which begs the
question how do you kill them how do you
kill the unkillable if I'm gonna inject
myself with healing factor what do I
need to look out for here well after
doing the research it looks like most
sources have overlooked the factors one
huge weakness the fatal flaw that makes
it easy to take down these two
characters well most sources have
overlooked it anyway and it's gonna
surprise you which one happens to be the
most accurate now first let me make it
clear that I know both characters have
died before but honestly it's tended to
result from some pretty cheap means so
I'm discounting all things that turn off
or counteract the healing factor that
quite frankly is a cop-out from writers
who wrote themselves into a corner by
making characters that were too powerful
in my analysis today we're finishing
these guys off in a perfectly natural
way that doesn't require some magical
anti heal additionally we're not pulling
a Dragon Ball Z and talking about
disintegrating every last cell to easy
as an explanation and quite frankly too
difficult to actually execute I mean an
uncanny x-men annual number 11 Wolverine
actually grows his entire body back from
a single drop of blood that's pretty
darn impressive like to see that in the
next x-men movie but in all seriousness
that's assuming you're able to
disintegrate him that fast which in and
of itself is a challenge I mean in venom
number nine Wolverine is able to heal
after a nuclear bomb destroys a village
a nuclear bomb and if you think he just
got lucky
he'll think again it happens another
time in ultimate Wolverine versus Hulk
lightning may not strike twice but
apparently nuclear warheads do look the
how to kill them problem is so bad that
even for
sir Charles Xavier doesn't know in his
Xavier protocols which are basically his
to-do list for when a powerful mutant
becomes a threat to the world he makes a
note to himself that reads the sleeve
decapitation and you think that this is
a guy who no rights I mean say what you
want about his nonstop cries of agony in
the animated series the guy is smart a
world leader in mutant abilities and yet
for super healers like Wolvie and DP
decapitation has also been disproven and
if he can't be hedeman if a bomb can't
disintegrate him fast enough what's
gonna do it I don't know two alternate
universe earth smashing together wow
what an oddly specific cosmic event I've
just described there but uh yes actually
that'll do it a multi universe earth
crash is the exact reason why Deadpool
is currently dead in the comics but
again I'm just a simple man with totally
average cosmic altering powers and I
need something that doesn't need to
escalate that quickly put those nuclear
warheads away put them away no good good
because the healing factors weakness is
much simpler than all this Wolverine and
especially Deadpool are vulnerable to
every single one of you viewers watching
right now and it all has to do with the
brain or more specifically memories
because sure these guys may be able to
regenerate their whole body from a
single drop of blood but one thing the
factor can't regenerate is memory let me
explain you see the first thing to
understand about memory formation and
why you can't regenerate memories is
that memories aren't stored they're not
physical things neurons the cells in the
brain are physical things and healing
factor is made to restore or replace
damaged cells but neurons are not the
same as memories and that's the problem
here
memories are signals a short-term memory
say the last diet coke you drank is a
pattern of signals in your mind hashtag
not sponsored hashtag just an addict
they drink a diet coke and the sensation
you get from it trigger a signal and
specific neurons in your prefrontal
cortex the area that stores short-term
memory that signal starts off as an
electric potential created by ions
moving in and out of the cells at one
end of the neuron that electrical signal
then triggers a chemical signal which is
a physical transfer of ions from one
neuron to another physically
transferring ions causes the electrical
signals in the next neuron to change
which is how the electrical and chemical
signal is carried across a lot of
neurons in short it's a chain reaction
so how then do these signals create
memories well each of your memories has
a specific chain reaction of signals
across a specific set of neurons your
diet coke signal started the first time
you cracked open a diet coke and felt
it's cool crisp refreshing burns slide
down your throat when you took that
first sip some of your taste neurons
sent a signal to some of your other
taste neurons in a specific pattern as
you thought hmm this is bubbly and
habit-forming the pattern of neurons
firing for your drinking diet coke
memory is different from the pattern for
your drinking orange juice memory or
your tasting chocolate pattern it's
specifically your diet coke pattern and
it gives you a specific memory of diet
coke I swear this isn't sponsored I just
have a problem now let me be clear all
electrical signals going on between two
individual neurons is basically the same
across the entirety of your brain what
makes something a memory is the specific
set of neurons that are activated in
association with a particular activity
the brain has a hundred million neurons
so if a few of them are involved in each
memory the brain has the theoretical
potential to store almost an infinite
number of memories based on how many
combinations of neurons there are and
how many unique patterns of signals you
can create in this way the brain is an
incredible storage system and how do
these things get stored well when you
experience something once a few of your
neurons start a signal pattern when you
think back to remember that experience
your brain is actually recreating that
same signal pattern again when you've
only experienced something once you can
only dimly recreate that pattern when
you think about it or it fades away
pretty fast if you want to improve your
recall of that experience you have to
reinforce it to do that you have to
experience it again so you drink a
second diet coke then another and before
long you have an emotional dependence
hashtag winning every time you repeat
the activity you trigger the same signal
pattern over and over again and your
brain starts to store that pattern in a
long-term memory area at the hippocampus
the neurons get a little bit closer to
each other and when that happens the
signal becomes stronger because
chemicals don't have to travel that far
the signals also become stronger
more frequent so over time those
memories become ingrained because the
signal patterns have been used so much
so then why can't Wolverine or Deadpool
just regenerate memories quite frankly
it's because there's nothing to
regenerate based on what we've outlined
the memory isn't part of the neuron it's
a pattern of signals between neurons
it's a tricky concept so let me explain
it this way when you learn about physics
you learn about electrical currents
which is a movement of electrons you can
think of memories in a lot the same way
in physics you can measure an electric
current you can turn it on and off etc
but it's not a physical thing you can
hold in your hand the current runs
through the wires and generates
electricity but just because you make a
wire doesn't mean there's automatically
a current running through it
in humans you can theoretically rebuild
the neurons they're a lot like the wires
running all through the brain but just
having the neurons there doesn't mean
that the right electrical pattern will
run through them memories only happen
when the specific neurons in your brain
have already experienced something new
cells don't come equipped with memories
when you regenerate an arm or a leg or a
creepy little baby hand those are new
body parts and their function doesn't
require you to have experienced
something before but newly regenerated
neurons are like baby neurons they're
brand new they're a blank slate which is
great because they're intact but bad
because only neurons with experiences
have memories new neurons have to start
from scratch even if they're all in the
right place to put it simply our two
super healers can grow back the brain
cells sure but not the brains electrical
patterns and as a result they're a blank
shell a husk of being without memories
think about it sure they may look like
Wolverine and Deadpool but they won't
act like them without those neural
connections they lose the elite fighting
training and arrogant personalities that
make them them it's something that in my
research literally no one has addressed
well almost no one
and that is the biggest irony of all in
the movie x-men origins Wolverine yeah
we're talking about that one a movie
mind you that is on practically every
list of worst superhero movies of all
time the villain striker shoots
Wolverine multiple times in the head
with adamantium bullets piercing his
skull and destroying his brain his line
as he does this
his brain may heal but his memory won't
grow back and of course this is exactly
what happens his brain is destroyed and
his memories go away Wolverine has
amnesia and remember this is the movie
so bad that it didn't give Deadpool a
mouth
Deadpool the Merc with a mouth you had
one job guys one then they chose to make
him look like Baraka
from Mortal Kombat because why not it's
a movie so bad that they mistakenly
think that wolves are the same as
Wolverines they can't get that right but
somehow they're the only one who's able
to get the science right I I don't even
know what to say and here's the thing
Deadpool is even more vulnerable than
Wolverine was in this scene Logan's
skeleton is coated with adamantium a
fictional metal that's basically the
hardest material ever created it took
bullets made of the stuff to puncture
his skull and damage his brain which
again is a huge oversight based on canon
laura round adamantium whatever this
movie sucks
Deadpool though on the other hand
doesn't have that advantage despite his
incredible healing abilities he still
just has a normal human skeleton just
one well-placed bullet hitting either
the frontal cortex or hippocampus would
knock out huge percentages of his memory
of course his healing abilities would
kick in and his head would repair itself
but it wouldn't have any of Wade
Wilson's memories Thor any memories at
all it would be completely empty like
wiping a hard drive destroy the brain
and Wade Wilson as we know him ceases to
be kind of like a zombie
I think Deadpool would appreciate that
sort of reference in the end I guess it
just goes to show oftentimes good
science doesn't result in good movies
but hey that's just a theory a film
theory and cut and before you go a huge
thank you once again to Bill and Melinda
Gates for reaching out to me to
pontificate a bit about superheroes now
that I'm wrapping up this video I
recommend taking the next five minutes
to read their annual letter by clicking
the link in the description if we're
talking about real-life superheroes than
the Gates's are two people who
definitely fall in that category using
their global influence to inspire others
to make a positive difference in the
world around them so read the letter and
get inspired to make your mark on the
world though you may not be the person
who cures cancer
rings electricity to central Africa
oddly specific reference I know but it's
in the letter remember that being a hero
doesn't require something big you can be
someone else's hero by just saying or
doing something small for someone else
so go ahead today tell your parents that
you love them tell a co-worker you
appreciate them take some time to get to
know the quiet kid who sits alone at
lunch the world would be a better place
for it one person at a time
and finally enough sappiness but let me
know in the comments if you could have
one superpower what would you want if
you say flying I don't blame you it's in
my top 3 along with healing factor and I
don't know the power of musical theater
they shall call me show tunes lad or
something nobody excuse me I gotta go
Chris pie fight Chris pie 5